ihr kennt das alle der Kellner bringt
die Rechnung ihr schaut einmal drauf und
denkt oh wer soll das bezahlen und dann
würden wir gerne alle sagen ja natürlich
andreas Scheuer zahlt die Rechnung denn
243 Millionen wow die haben wir als
Steuerzahler gerade echt nicht zu
verschenken das findet auch der
Nachfolger von andreas Scheuer
Verkehrsminister Volker Wissing denn es
geht ja nicht um etwas was man aus der
Portokasse bezahlen kann sondern um 243
Millionen Euro also knapp eine viertel
Milliarde Steuergelder für die Menschen
arbeiten mussten und die haben ein Recht
darauf zu wissen wie geht das jetzt
weiter warum haftet niemand oder haftet
jemand vielleicht andreas Scheuer wissen
lässt das gerade juristisch prüfen kann
man den Ex-Verkehrsminister für die
mautpleite persönlich haftbar machen
manche haben sie jetzt schon festgelegt
ich bin der Meinung dass Andreas teuer
ein Teil seines privaten Vermögens dafür
bezahlen sollte mal angenommen
tatsächlich ich persönlich haftbar zu
machen was passiert dann habe ich einen
Verwaltungsrechtler gefragt wenn Herr
scheuer keine 240 Millionen Euro hat ich
kenne deine persönliche
Vermögensverhältnisse nicht aber ich
habe die starke Vermutung dass er die
nicht hat dann wird man wenn man das
vollstreckt wird er scheuer aller
Voraussicht nach in die also das ist
jetzt sehr ins Blaue hinein gesprochen
in die Privatinsolvenz rutschen teuer
als Flaschensammler zugegeben das ist
schwer vorstellbar aber lasst uns diesen
Fall mal ganz seriös durchspielen
ministerhaftung gibt's die und wenn nein
wie wahrscheinlich ist dass sie kommt
all das klären wir heute bei inside-
[Applaus]
ich bin Christiane hübscher und ich
beschäftige mich im ZDF-Hauptstadtstudio
vor allem mit Verkehrspolitik andreas
Scheuer und die Maut dazu habe ich
wirklich viel berichtet und darüber ging
auch tatsächlich unser allererstes Video
hier bei inside-politics das ist drei
Jahre her und damals sind wir der Frage
nachgegangen warum ist er eigentlich
nicht zurückgetreten bekanntlich ist
teuer inzwischen auch ohne Rücktritt
nicht mehr Minister sondern hinter
Bänkler im Bundestag aber jetzt haben
wir alle die fette Rechnung bekommen für
den Maut Schlammassel oder wie Herr
scheuer ist nennt Skandal richtig auch
Rücktritt Nebelkerzen ja und dann war
doch da noch dieses andere Wort
vergessen genau ja das trifft es alles
schon ganz gut und wegen der Maut die
nie kam muss die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland
243 Millionen Schadenersatz bezahlen
243 Millionen Euro was könnten wir
Steuerzahler uns davon nicht alles
kaufen ich habe es mal nachgerechnet zum
Beispiel 60 Millionen warme Schulessen
oder sechs neue ICE für die Deutsche
Bahn oder 16 Leopard 2 Panzer für die
Ukraine aber das Geld ist wahrscheinlich
futsch weil andreas Scheuer damals die
mautverträge ach lange Geschichte ich
finde die Kollegen von Frontal haben das
ganze Drama in ihrer Schluss Satire toll
neulich noch mal in wenigen Sekunden
wirklich toll zusammengefasst weil ja
klar war das hat der Scheuer die
mautverträge Ende 2018 schon mal
unterschrieben ein halbes Jahr bevor der
Europäische Gerichtshof erklärt hat die
Maut sei eben nicht Europa rechtskonform
ich hatte andere Rechtsauffassung als
der EuGH ja das ist klar aber die Frage
ist welche Rechtsauffassung gilt exakt
und deshalb Platz der Steuerzahler jetzt
243 Millionen Schadensersatz fakt ist
Andreas scheuert wurde gewarnt aus
seinem Ministerium auch die
mautbetreiber die die Millionen jetzt
kriegen für ihren entgangenen Gewinn wir
haben den Minister damals angeboten zu
warten mit der Unterschrift bis der EuGH
geurteilt hat aber das wollte er nicht
fachlich war es ein mehr als
waghalsiges Unterfangen einen solchen
Vertrag zu unterzeichnen wo man wusste
dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit sehr hoch
ist dass diese Entscheidung auf
europäischer Ebene gegen die PKW-Maut in
Deutschland ausfallen wird das Ganze ist
vorsätzlich passiert er hat das ganze
nur gemacht um den Vertrag noch vor der
Landtagswahl abzuschließen dachte mit
der wie ersten Hand der ausländermaut
populistisch Punkte für die CSU machen
sich nennt das Volker Wissing
vorsätzlich sagt Anton Hofreiter und
genau das ist die Frage die jetzt
juristisch zu bewerten ist
fahrlässig oder Vorsatz
war das fahrlässig oder war das Vorsatz
fragen wir mal unseren
Verwaltungsrechtler nach seiner
Einschätzung ich denke schon dass man
wird sagen können dass oder zumindest
gut vertreten kann dass der ehemalige
Minister scheuer hier fahrlässig
gehandelt hat oder auch grob fahrlässig
ob es wirklich vorsätzlich war dass
würde ich vielleicht bezweifeln Vorsatz
dürfte also schwer nachzuweisen sein
auch deswegen weil andreas Scheuer nicht
eigennützig gehandelt hat er hat sich
das Geld ja nicht in die eigene Tasche
gesteckt aber selbst wenn er nur grob
fahrlässig gehandelt haben sollte dürfte
es für persönliche Haftung nicht reichen
denn Minister sind keine Beamten sie
fallen unter das bundesministergesetz
und das kennt keine regresshaftung
Minister kann man eigentlich nur haftbar
machen wenn Sie einen absolutes Recht
verletzen das meint Eigentum Leib und
Leben spricht ein Minister muss schon
silberne Löffel klauen oder das
Kanzleramt anzünden damit man ihn dran
kriegt wenn man das ändern wollte müsste
man das Gesetz ändern da muss man sich
allerdings darüber auch im Klaren sein
dass das die Entscheid volksfreude und
die Entscheidungsfreiheit dem
Ministerinnen und Minister natürlich
erheblich beeinträchtigen kann und die
Frage ist natürlich ob wir das wollen
oder ob wir auch wollen dass
Ministerinnen und Ministerinnen auch mal
ins Risiko gehen auch wenn bestimmte
Dinge dann eben mal in die Hose gehen
genau denn in der Politik geht es ja oft
um viel Geld und welcher Minister welche
Ministerin würde sich noch trauen große
Schecks zu unterschreiben wenn über ihn
immer das Damoklesschwert der
persönlichen Haftung hänge was meint ihr
dazu schreibt uns in die Kommentare
Beamte sind haftbar
anders sieht es eben bei Beamten aus da
gibt es diesen Fall der früheren Bonner
Oberbürgermeisterin Bärbel Dietmann sie
ist verantwortlich für einen riesen
bausskandal in Bonn durch einen
Konferenzzentrum entstand der Stadt ein
Millionenschaden und dann wurde sie
tatsächlich zunächst in erster Instanz
zu einer Million Euro Schadensersatz
verurteilt weil sie ihre Dienstpflichten
Zitat grob fahrlässig verletzt habe
dagegen hat sie Berufung eingelegt und
sich gerade kürzlich erst mit der Stadt
Bonn geeinigt auf die Zahlung von
200.000 €. damit ist das Urteil
hinfällig aber Diekmann haftet dennoch
persönlich für ihren Fehler der Bund der
Steuerzahler der findet das natürlich
gut das wissen die Haftungsfrage für die
mautstrafe jetzt prüfen lässt er wünscht
sich dass solche Vorgehen bei
Steuergeldverschwendung zur Regel
gemacht werden da fallen mir noch einige
Projekte ein beispielsweise der Berliner
Flughafen oder verkorkste Bundestags
Bauten außerdem brauchen wir die
Erweiterung des Strafgesetzbuchs um den
Straftatbestand der haushaltsune das
fordert Holznagel und nun
erstmal passiert andreas Scheuer gar
nichts er kriegt weiter seine
Abgeordneten Diät und die will ihm nicht
mal Toni Hofreiter nehmen ist gewählt da
Abgeordneter und so lange gewählte
Abgeordneter ist soll er dafür auch Geld
bekommen aber die Leute sollten sich
natürlich schon auch überlegen ob sie
immer wieder solche disaster Figuren
wieder wählen wollen und irgendwann wird
Volker Wissing als amtierender
Verkehrsminister rauskommen und uns
sagen was die Prüfung seiner Gutachter
ergeben hat hier die Prognose unseres
verwaltungsrechtlers ich gehe davon aus
dass andreas Scheuer im Ergebnis nicht
wird haften müssen es wird danach eine
politische Debatte darüber geben ob es
sinnvoll ist die
Haftungsvorschriften für Ministerinnen
und Minister auszuweiten und sie den
Beamtenrecht anzugleichen der
wahrscheinlichste Ausgang also außer
Spesen nichts gewesen und was sagt
eigentlich Herr scheuer dazu ich kann
den Unmut sehr gut verstehen über dieses
gescheiterte Projekt
ärgere ich mich wohl selbst am
allermeisten
ihr seid jetzt hoffentlich ein bisschen
klüger und ich freue mich wenn ihr uns
weiter schaut bis zum nächsten Mal